[Music]
welcome to the Pete Holmes show some
other Holmes's are here again my father
my brother and my uncle Larry are all
here today good to see you guys thanks
for being here representing Boston all
right okay okay I start by telling you
this last week I was in the car with
four people from work yeah don't worry
about it
I Drive whatever but uh the reason I
bring it up it can be tricky to having
four people in the car trying to pick
what you're all gonna listen to you know
I'm talking about so to alleviate the
situation I just took my iPod I said
here's Spotify put on whatever music you
want and you know what we put on of all
the choices on all the internet Shania
Twain's that don't impress me much yeah
you're right to a block why because we
love pop music you know who else loves
pop music everybody why it's the best
suddenly we got all the windows down
we're singing along we surprisingly know
all the words including the sassy
talking parts link okay so you're Brad
Pitt
but there's this stigma still to this
day against pop we all feel this
pressure to have cool hip music tastes
you know like oh oh me oh no I don't
listen to pump pump no whatever you
heard of backwash amazing
it's a synthesizer playing over the
sound of a trash compactor then a puppet
freestyles it's so good sometimes you're
not in the mood for a puppet freestyling
over strings and garbage sometimes you
just want a good pop beat gives you a
pulse I mean ideally you already have a
pulse but pop music gives you like a
sexy pulse your heartbeat is here but
pop music puts the beat here ribbon
Beyonce Kesha they make you do this
ideally something better than that
someone accepts my dancing your body
involuntarily goes into sex mode when
pop music is on I don't know something
about that rhythm makes you go
I got a this pocket air right in front
of me what if this is how I had sex it
is it is even pop songs get the job done
someone like you by Adele you kidding me
that is a lonely song about being lonely
and ideally you listen to it alone
bathtub candles red wine you know a good
mom and cry but it works anywhere that
song can come on in to McDonald's every
single person will put down their Big
Mac and reflect on their capacity to
love sure the sauce is special but
where's that special someone for me
[Applause]
now I know classical music is good for
you you know it's supposed to I don't
know make your brain grow or some
I'm just saying it's okay to mix it up
people play classical music for their
unborn baby like oh yeah Peter jr. loves
Vivaldi sure he's a fetus but he's also
a genius
he's a genius a genius fetus he's a
genius we're really really hoping it
comes out wearing a vintage tuxedo with
coattails sure we'll have to hose it off
but still but I say play some Katy Perry
for the fetus to mix it up you're so
fixated on feelin him kick how'd you
like to feel that baby fist pump baby a
pump in Tubac so don't be embarrassed to
like something popular sometimes you
don't want a souffle from a five-star
restaurant or a truffle oil infused
whatever the sometimes you just
want a fluffernutter and that's what
justin timberlake is a fluffernutter
mostly white with a dash of brown and
delicious good help now it's like hell
I've been at the dentist in the middle
of having a cavity filled and had my
mood immediately lifted by the faint
background in of in the air tonight it's
like the worst situation but that song
so great there's like can you open a
little wider for me I'm like I sure can
[Applause]
[Music]